[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much good evening ladies
and gentlemen tonight we are here to
debate something as contemporary as it
is contentious the motion before us
boldly states the world should recognize
Jerusalem as Israel's capital it
promises to be a pretty intense 90
minutes but arguably less fraught than
your alternative 90 minutes this evening
watching England V Tunisia so first of
all thank you all for being here in
choosing us a special shout out to the
11 year olds in their sports kits we're
really happy that you came to and just
think panel the weight of expectation
upon our shoulders could be so much
worse
moving the United States Embassy to
Israel in Israel to Jerusalem as Donald
Trump did a month ago constitutes a
momentous show of support and friendship
to Israel it grants Israel that same
legitimacy to establish its own capital
that is taken as a given by every other
country in the world it is also a
reckless move a move that pushes peace
further away than ever a reality
underscored when Israeli forces killed
dozens of protesting Palestinians in
Gaza as that embassy ceremony was under
way just 50 miles away other countries
in accordance with the UN recognition of
Jerusalem as a corpus sefirot 'm in
other words a separate body place their
embassies in tel aviv so should that now
change or is it the worst kind of
opportunists short-term meddling the
cost of which may well turn out to be
enormous this debate invites huge
questions about so much Middle East
policy but tonight we want to stick as
far as we can to the motion itself this
is not just about Trump this is not just
about America it's about whether the
should recognize Jerusalem as Israel's
capital does it seem let's be honest
obvious to you that whatever the UN says
whatever countries say publicly
Jerusalem is the capital of Israel or
does it seem an unnecessary and illegal
provocation at a time when the peace
process is flatlining now on the way in
you voted with your gut instincts will
you still feel that way at the end we
have as you can see before you a
phenomenal panel of speakers tonight 2
for 2 against you'll hear from each and
then I'll encourage questions she begs
concise questions from the floor
will hear a brief summing up and I'll
ask you to vote again and we'll bring
you that final tally and compare the to
compare the change the direction of
travel at the end a last word as much
for those on the panel perhaps as those
asking questions we know how much
passion this subject arouses we know how
quickly tempers and feelings can become
inflamed by all means make your
arguments and your rhetoric as robust
and compelling as you can but we're
going to attempt tonight to keep it
civil in here our first speaker then for
the motion is natasha hausdorff she's a
barrister at six pump court chambers and
a director of the NGO UK lawyers for
Israel she previously clerked for the
president of the Israeli Supreme Court
in Jerusalem her family ties to
Jerusalem date back to 1846 now she's
going to speak for just under 10 minutes
at the podium
there'll be no interventions allowed
during the opening speeches if you hear
me click my glass it means there's one
minute to go Natasha the floor is yours
ladies and gentlemen good evening
Thank You Emily and the team at
intelligence squared is it a pleasure to
be here and yet I'm also puzzled as to
why it is that we must in fact all
gather here on a Monday evening while
England plays her first World Cup game
to discuss what must be self-evident
that Jerusalem is the capital of Israel
why is this even a question should the
world recognize Jerusalem why well I
suppose similarly for millennium the
world did not recognize that the earth
was round there is at the heart of
controversy over recognition of
Jerusalem as Israel's capital a series
of myths and before anything I want to
take this opportunity to debunk those
myths in particular the myth of
occupation because the framework of the
law of occupation applies where a
sovereign is how stood from its
territory now there is no State of
Palestine there never was a state of
Palestine there may one day be such a
state but that depends on negotiations
and factors which we simply don't have
the time to be able to address properly
this evening absent any sovereign from
which land could have been occupied the
notion of occupation in a legal sense
simply does not have a leg to stand on
and the term occupation used in this
context is purely a political term
issues over territory go to the heart of
the matter and date back to the very
establishment of the State of Israel in
1948 Israel was born
out of the previous British Mandate of a
geographical area called Palestine now
when a state emerges out of the
pre-existing colonial entity there is a
principle a fundamental principle of
international law that applies to
determine and regulate the delineation
of that new States territory that
principle is called ot precede ettus
URIs and it dictates that the new state
inherits the boundaries of the
pre-existing colonial entity it's been
applied to the emergence of states in
South America it's been applied and
governed the dissolution of the former
Yugoslavia and it's been consistently
applied in Asia and in Africa after
Israel's war of independence when
partition was rejected by the Arabs and
in which it was set upon by five Arab
armies seeking to annihilate it the only
new sovereign entity to emerge from the
previous existing British Mandate was
Israel and for the application of this
fundamental principle of international
law dictates that Israel inherits the
pre-existing boundaries of the British
Mandate that preceded it and indeed
Israel's peace treaties with its
neighboring States to date with Egypt
and with Jordan reinforce this reading
because those treaties ratify borders
between Israel and its neighbors
explicitly based on those pre-existing
boundaries of the British Mandate that
is the legal situation which leads me to
the next myth in legality people will
tell you that this that and the other in
respect of Israel is illegal because
they have nothing else to say in
international law the boundaries of
Israel Jerusalem as its capital and
Israel's current administration of the
disputed territories which it acquired
in defensive Wars is categorically legal
not only was there never a state of
Palestine but contrary to an
increasingly circulated
misrepresentation until relatively
recently there was no such thing as
Palestinian Arab national identity my
grandparents were Palestinians Jewish
Palestinians designated as such by the
British because they were living in
British Mandate Palestine in fact my
family was living in Jerusalem well over
a hundred years before Yasser Arafat who
was born in Egypt invented the concept
of exclusive Palestinian Arab national
identity in the 1960s ok myths debunked
let's talk about the city which has been
the epicentre of Jewish prayer and
identity for the last 3,000 years the
capital of the only Jewish state it's
worth noting that there are 22 Arab
states 22 Arab capitals one of them is
in Jordan where Arabs from Mandate
Palestine form the majority of the
population but Jerusalem is special
Jerusalem is unique it does after all
host the places the holy places of the
Abrahamic religions now Israel's
Declaration of Independence resolved
that Israel would safeguard the holy
places of all religions
during the Jordanian occupation between
1948 and 1967 there was no freedom of
religion in Jerusalem Jews were
ethnically cleansed from the city 58
synagogues were desecrated Jews were
prevented from accessing their holiness
the holiest site 38,000 Jewish graves in
the ancient cemetery on the Mount of
Olives were systematically desecrated my
own great-grandfather's tombstone the
honor mayor hausdorff
was used to pave a nearby road hundreds
of Torah scrolls and thousands of holy
books were plundered and burned
Asha's the christian population had
restrictions imposed on it so that many
chose to leave the city after liberating
the old city in 1967 moshe dayan then
Minister defense famously declared we've
reunited the city the capital of Israel
never to part it again to our Arab
neighbours Israel extends the hand of
peace and to people of all faiths we
guarantee full freedom of worship we've
come not to conquer the holy places of
others but to live with others in
harmony let's look around the region for
a moment at the Banyan Valley or Palmyra
blown up by Isis at sites in Alexandria
destroyed by the Muslim Brotherhood and
at Gaza more recently where Hamas
bulldozed an ancient Canaanite
four-and-a-half thousand year old Bronze
Age city known as tel s Sakana
sites of religious and cultural heritage
are only safe in the one democracy in
the region now Israel has of its own
volition given authority to the
Jordanian wax over the Temple Mount the
wax abused that authority by destroying
archaeology and allowing terrorist
activity Israel guarantees freedom of
religion in perpetuity in all sites the
one exception is that Jews are
prohibited from preying on the Temple
Mount
a concession the Israeli Authority has
made in the name of peaceful coexistence
and let's get to the real positive note
in all of this which is that recognition
of the actuality Israel is never going
to relinquish Jerusalem is the most
positive step that we can make towards
peace any real peace can never be based
on fabrications or falsehoods and any
negotiations that start from a position
of fantasy do not have a hope of success
the proof of this is that in 70 years we
have not achieved the piece that we
yearn for so let us take a reality check
and I promise you that any Palestinian
leader who genuinely seeks to negotiate
a solution will be enormous ly
advantaged
by the fact that the world
accepts reality the violent riots and
terror attacks committed by the genocide
or terrorist regime Hamas attempting to
breach the border fence into Israel in
the last few months has not in response
to the recognition of Jerusalem it's an
objection to Israel's very existence the
embassy move is just an excuse but even
if for one moment you thought that they
were resultant from that move from
recognition of as Israel's capital shame
on the notion that threats and violence
ought to make right-thinking people like
us ought to prevent us from doing the
right thing ever we don't have to go
back to the fact that Jerusalem was the
capital of the Jewish people 3,000 years
ago or two that every year Jews in the
Diaspora say next year in Jerusalem or
to the fact that at every Jewish wedding
the groom utters the immortal words if I
forget you O Jerusalem let my right hand
forget its skill all we need is to
extend to Israel the same courtesy that
we extend to every single country in the
world every country has the right to
choose its capital and that choice is
respected by the international community
I mentioned at the start that for
millennia the world did not recognize
that the earth was round I kid you not
this still exists Google the Flat Earth
Society there are people that still
believe that the world is flat there are
people who don't recognize that
Jerusalem is the capital of the State of
Israel
don't let that be you ladies and
gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
a provocative opening there Natasha
thank you very much
guard a commie is our first speaker
against the motion she's a leading
Palestinian activist academic and writer
she's a research fellow at the Institute
of Arab and Islamic studies at the
University of Exeter and she's the
author of return a Palestinian memoir
born in Jerusalem gada
you have 10 minutes welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much well all I can say
to you is after that if you believe that
you'll believe anything
[Applause]
I can't I don't have the time to go into
refuting every single of these old
chestnuts that natasha has produced
which I thought had actually died but
they're still being reiterated by
defenders of Israel I'm sorry to say
anyway the short answer to the
proposition that the world should
recognize Jerusalem as Israel's capital
is a resounding no it should not the
world should not recognize Jerusalem as
the capital of Israel because to do so
would mean that the world was
recognizing illegal occupation land
theft expulsion of the native population
and discrimination against those of the
natives who remain in Jerusalem it is to
recognize illegal settlement building to
recognize in short serial violations of
Palestinian human rights and
international law ok let's have a few
facts the situation which may surprise
some of you is this Israel has no legal
title to either west or east jerusalem
the reality is that as the tasha
mentioned the status of Jerusalem was
decided by a UN resolution in 1947 that
it would be administered under
international jurisdiction Israel
however took over West Jerusalem and
started to behave as if it were
preparing for for that to become its
capital city but Israel has no legal
title to West Jerusalem its presence in
Jerusalem is a de facto presence in
other words it's recognized as a reality
but not in
not by rights and that is why the
majority of nations do not have their
embassies in West Jerusalem now the East
Jerusalem is under belligerent
occupation since 1967 and the fact that
Israel annexed East Jerusalem is also
illegal now president Trump's decision
to go ahead and recognize Jerusalem as
the capital of Israel despite all this
air in itself quite apart from what you
may think about the wisdom such a move
actually confers no legality on Israel
with regard to Jerusalem so it doesn't
actually make any difference the legal
position but you know this is a man who
sent his daughter to celebrate as you
heard Emily say to celebrate drink
champagne with Israel's leaders while
Israeli snipers were shooting dead 120
Palestinian men women and children is
this a model the world wants to follow I
don't think so
now I have to confess that the
proposition has a very special
significance for me I was born in
Jerusalem before there was an Israel it
is my native city we were driven out in
1948 to make room for the creation of
Israel in my homeland my family house is
still in Jerusalem in West Jerusalem
successive Israeli families and
individuals have occupied it but it is
our family home since 1948 I have had to
witness Israel's repeat
of salt on Jerusalem's territory its
topography its history and all the time
Israel stressing to the world that Jews
have an emotional and religious
attachment to the city you heard just
now the Hackney trace the capital of the
Jewish people I don't know what that
means
a capital is normally the capital of a
country it's not the capital of a people
however you hear this all the time and
it's all it is is throwing dust in the
eyes
however attached you are to some place
or other it does not mean you can seize
it and own it that is a fundamental law
of the international order otherwise
where would we all be you know I'm often
having to use a an example I'm going to
give you it sounds absurd but it's in a
way it's quite parallel you see
supposing I told you that I have and my
family has a very strong attachment to
Buckingham Palace and that I have
documents documents which show that my
ancestors preceded the Queen of England
really do you think that would give me
the right to throw the Queen out and
take her place I don't think so so the
question of recognizing Jerusalem is
Israel's capital really what it does
amount to in the end is going along with
the brazen attempt on the part of Israel
again and again to pull the wool over
people's eyes to hold on to what it
isn't
Israel's to keep that's what this is all
about and I don't think looking at this
audience you're gonna fall for that
you're not gonna fall for that which is
why I urge you
to oppose the proposition and vote
against it thank you
but I think you gotta call me there
speaking of land theft discrimination
and illegal settlement you have a couple
of minutes left on the clock if there's
anything more that you want to add god
that's nice it's the first thing that's
ever happened to me I'm 20 is double the
number that is recognized as the
killings in Gaza no I'm afraid not
120 in one day you can check that with
whatever source you want 120 in one day
yes in one day sorry sorry we can come
back on that day we can come back to
that was just allowing you to UM day you
pick it up with a jacket you're right
but listen even if it was 20 you think
it would be all right you see okay I'm
going to introduce our second speaker
for the motion the world should
recognize Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel
I heard Olmert the Prime Minister of the
State of Israel from 2006 to 2009 he
worked towards give us a chance
he worked towards a peace agreement with
the Palestinian President Mahmoud Abbas
which he believes they were very close
to concluding he also served as mayor of
Jerusalem from 1993 to 2003 a hurdle met
you have the floor for 10 minutes
[Music]
thank you very much I entirely subscribe
to the fundamental principle of what
Natasha said before about the centrality
of Jerusalem is the capital of the state
of Israel and is the center part of
Jewish history but first and foremost as
the capital of the State of Israel
secondly I'm forced to say that the
numbers that you have spelled out
mrs. Comey are entirely false there were
62 victims in Gaza terrible I am said
for each and every one of them but the
problem of this debate that we hold all
the time is that you can't stick to the
facts
you have to exaggerate in order to try
and dramatize it because you arguments
are not strong enough now I I don't say
it here for the sake of winning the
support of this very distinguished group
of people I must say I am utterly
impressed by the fact that you prefer us
over the English team in the Mondial I
mean I'd watch it myself but thank you
very much for coming I want to say that
there is always a danger then we will
try to argue about all kinds of small
petty facts and we will get stuck in the
corner instead of talking about the
basic fundamental things which are
essential for this discussion and
therefore what I want to do is to take
the position that was spelled out by
Natasha one step forward and say this it
will say by Emily that I was Prime
Minister of State of Israel are
negotiated with the president of the
Palestine
authority and we were that close to
reach an agreement had a Palestinian
leader said yes to what I proposed and
this is what I proposed what I proposed
and I proposed now which can solve this
issue in a just and correct manner for
everyone involved what I proposed was
the Jerusalem will be the capital of the
State of Israel there is no question
about it it is and it should be but
Jerusalem not Beit Hanina and not ISA
Weah and Ocho fat and not a refugee came
in to a fault inaudible Makabe and all
the villages which are now considered to
be part of the municipality of Jerusalem
and which I tried very much to take care
of when I was mayor of Jerusalem and
build and improve the quality of life
much more than any of the Palestinians
living under the the tyranny of the
Hamas in Gaza but all of these villages
are not part of the history of Jerusalem
as far as we as Jews and Israelis are
concerned
therefore my idea is very simple
Jerusalem is the capital of Israel all
the Arab neighborhoods which surround
the city of Jerusalem are not as far as
I'm concerned they can be the capital of
the Palestinians no problem take it now
take it I proposed it now I'm not
talking theoretically I'm not talking
hypothetically I negotiated with the
Palestinian representative the only
person amongst the Palestinians perhaps
the only person in any our community in
the world which was elected
democratically Mahmoud Abbas a decent
partner to negotiations I proposed to
him
that all the Arab neighborhoods around
Jerusalem will be part of the
Palestinian state I am in favor of a
two-state solution absolutely and that
all these villages will be the capital
of the Palestinian state Jerusalem
wheezed a neighbourhood state were built
after 67 will be the State of Israel
then there is one issue the Holy Basin I
proposed again not theoretically not
hypothetically as the Prime Minister of
the State of Israel on behalf of the
State of Israel officially I proposed it
to the Palestinians and I say the Holy
Basin will be defined accurately and a
trust of five nations will be appointed
by the security National Security
Council of the United Nations approved
by the General Assembly of the United
Nations to administer the Holy Basin
without an exclusive sovereignty for
anyone all right what else unless
someone wants to say it's not the issue
of Jerusalem and you could hear it and I
hope that my friend is a straw will not
subscribe to this ridiculous position
that really what lies behind it is not
East and West Jerusalem is not supposed
to be capital of Israel it level is not
supposed to exist as a Jewish state in
the first place and that's lies behind
it because I can understand that you can
say I am against having a Buddhist as
part of the capital of Israel I don't
disagree but to say that Israel has no
right to have its capital in Jerusalem
in any part of Jerusalem this is
basically to say that we are not in
favor of having Israel all together
and this was the official position of
all the Arab countries during 1947 and
that's they rejected the 47 resolution
of the United Nation not Israel so to
sum it up Jerusalem is the capital of
the State of Israel I was proud to be
the mayor of the city at a time that we
celebrated the third millennium of
Jerusalem as the capital starting at the
times not only of the Jewish people but
of the Jewish people in the sovereign
state of Israel at that time in the time
of King David and since then it never
seems to be the center of Jewish life
and the center of Israeli life since the
State of Israel was created there has to
remain the parts which are today within
the municipal framework of Jerusalem and
which are not part of Jewish history
should be part of the Palestinian state
that ought to be created and that they
will become the capital of the
Palestinian state according more or less
to the lines of 1967
now I proposed it on behalf of the State
of Israel again and I never got a
positive answer from the Palestinians so
with all due respect don't try to
distort the basic facts we are prepared
to recognize the position the status of
the Palestinians first of all we are
prepared and it could have been resolved
and if you will ask the President of the
Palestinian Authority dr. Mahmoud Abbas
he will confirm it because he did
confirm it time and again publicly since
we negotiated that this was proposed by
me
he never said no I have to be honest II
never said no but he never said yes
which could have resolved this
historical conflict on a basis which is
entirely acceptable to the international
community now you guys want to argue
with Trump maybe I also who cares I'm
talking about the fundamental fact that
Jerusalem has been was is and will be
the capital of the State of Israel and
that all the surroundings of Jerusalem
which are inhabited by Palestinians and
which are considered to be Jerusalem by
the Palestinians should be the capital
of the Palestinian state which will be
created on the day that the Palestinians
will say yes to my proposal thank you
very much
[Applause]
I heard on that they're former Prime
Minister of the State of Israel on why
that deal never got through in favor of
a two-state solution
our last speaker then our second speaker
against the motion is Jack Straw cabinet
minister in the governments of Tony
Blair and Gordon Brown he served as
foreign secretary Home Secretary leader
of the Commons and Justice Secretary
Jack Straw welcome you have ten minutes
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
I want to begin this debate sort of left
field but it's very important that I do
to say something I never thought that I
would have to say but I've been so
appalled by some by some of the recent
example of anti-semitism in my party
that I feel I must do say
[Applause]
I've been in continuous membership of
the Labour Party since 1960 58 years for
almost he work out how old I was when I
started for almost all of that period
the issue of anti-semitism within my
party simply did not arise where a party
born of the idea of equality for all and
proud of our consistent record of anti
racism and of opposing discrimination on
the grounds of religion moreover because
people of the Jewish faith had in the
Holocaust suffered a greater genocide
than any peoples in human history no one
in my party ever sought to dance on the
head of a pin and seek to suggest
disgustingly that it was possible to
distinguish racism from anti-semitism
until recently that is when in the last
three years some in the Labour Party
have tolerated or condoned some
completely unacceptable examples of
anti-semitism as I will explain I do not
agree with the stance taken by
successive governments in Israel towards
the settlements in the occupied West
Bank and in East Jerusalem nor to the
recent decision of the US administration
to recognize Jerusalem as it's not
Israel's capital and to move its embassy
there from Tel Aviv but I defend
absolutely the right of Israel to
prosper in peace and security within its
internationally recognized borders and I
condemn those whether within or without
my party who somehow conflate their
opposition to particular policies for
the time being of the government of
Israel with opposition or worse to those
of the Jewish faith or the right of
Israel to exist at all now I've been to
Israel and the occupied territories on
many occasions and of course I
understand that two Israelis Jerusalem
is their capital I'm not trying to tell
you what is patently not the case
and Natasha of course I understand that
but I think it's also important to
understand that two Palestinians
Jerusalem is their capital - and it's
this conflict of perceptions which is
very powerful which lies at the heart of
the international debate as to when and
in what circumstances it would be right
to report international recognition to
Jerusalem as Israel's capital and
meanwhile for international and
diplomatic purposes to sustain the
current situation where Tel Aviv should
be the site of diplomatic missions and I
listened with care - what Natasha said
on this issue of legality and illegality
and I don't want to get bogged down in
that debate but just to say that Natasha
that those who believe the world is
round and those who believe the world is
flat might be the other way around on
this issue and that in terms of
illegality there is a raft of United
Nations Security Council resolutions
which do declare that Israel's
occupation of the occupied territories
that's why it's called that it is
unlawful that its settlements are
unlawful that for example the
[Applause]
resolution four seven eight passed by
the Security Council in 1980 it was one
which declared that great concern about
the enactment of the law of Jerusalem in
the neset and reaffirmed censored in the
strongest terms and don't forget this
the United States could have veto this
resolution but it didn't do so and
affirms that the enactment of the basic
law by Israel constitutes a violation of
international law and does not affect
the continued application of the Geneva
Conventions etc in the Palestinian and
other Arab territories occupied since
June 1967 including Jerusalem so that as
I just to come back to this the issue is
how we deal with this conflict between
Israel and the Palestinians which has
dogged the region continues to threaten
that whether one likes it or not the
security of Israel and everybody living
with within Israel and is it I mean
worse than than a running saw now my
view is if happiness is no different
from that which has been taken by
successive British governments including
the present administration led by Teresa
may this is what our in Prime Minister
not of my party but I agree with her
said when President Trump announced his
decision on the 8th of December last
year it is may sever I quote we disagree
with the u.s. decision to move its
embassy to Jerusalem and to recognize
Jerusalem as is as the Israeli capital
before a final status agreement has been
reached we believe it is unhelpful in
terms of prospects for peace in the
region the British Embassy to Israel is
based in Tel Aviv and we have no plans
to move it our position she went on on
the status of Israel is clear and
long-standing it should be determined in
the negotiated settlement between the
Israelis and the Palestinians and
Jerusalem should ultimately be the
shared capital of the Israeli and
West Indian states I just pause at that
to say there that that's what we did it
here with respect to them either from
Natasha or from our heart about sharing
Jerusalem and not sharing the suburbs
their heart
[Applause]
I mean your remember that time Weitzman
I mean your won't Britt remember
personal anymore than I do but you
remember the story that Haim Weitzman
when he was trying to negotiating what
became the Balfour Declaration was
offered Uganda by the British government
I'm not making this up he was offered
Uganda by the British government as a
site for an Israeli state and he then
replied well would you like to the Brits
who were talking to
would you like Paris as as the capital
of Great Britain I mean the answer these
territories and any cities have enormous
symbolic before importance of course
they do for every member of the Jewish
faith and particularly what members of
the Jewish faith have gone through but
they also have huge importance for
Palestinians as well whether they are
Palestinians to a Christian of women
there are great many or Palestinians who
are Muslim as well and mrs. may went on
to say in line with relevant Security
Council resolutions we regard East
Jerusalem as part of occupied
Palestinian territories and she added
that she now urged the White House to
bring forward detailed proposals for an
israeli-palestinian settlement so this
issue about whether not whether Israelis
should recognize Jerusalem as the
capital of Israel I understand it that's
all Israelis do recognize it but it's
whether the world should recognize
Jerusalem as Israel's capital comes down
to this what approach is most likely to
assist in securing a long-term
resolution to this conflict which is so
bedeviled a region for 70 years now
there are may be those in Israel and
elsewhere who believe that no solution
is possible that the world when the
region simply have to live with the
facts on the ground and that's what I
took from what Natasha had to say
however like the British government and
almost all in the international
community
I profoundly disagree the condition in
which many Palestinians have to live is
an affront to any concept we all share
of human dignity to continued
encroachments of Palestinian land
the forcible evacuation which I have
witnessed of Palestinian residents to
make way for Israeli settlements is
unacceptable and it's unlawful in
international law and has caused
unnecessary and untold human misery but
I also question whether maintaining the
status quo is remotely in the interests
of the vast majority of his raela
citizens who are of the Jewish faith I
was involved in negotiations led by
President Bush and Tony Blair which led
to the 2002 roadmap and I also greatly
applaud the efforts made by our heart
omlette when he was Prime Minister
it was difficult then and is become more
difficult any resolution will inevitably
involve concessions by both sides but
when one critical issue in those
negotiations will have to be the status
of Jerusalem in the situation where
Israel because of the facts on the
ground will inevitably hold many of the
best cards the views taken by the
international community and by Her
Majesty's Government is that agreement
for Israel to achieve international
recognition of Jerusalem as its capital
would have to be matched by concessions
to the Palestinians on other matters and
essentially what President Trump has
sought to do is to take away a critical
part in those negotiations making it
that much more difficult for a
settlement to be reached this has never
been announced no it's arguing with
Israelis not to recognize Jerusalem as
its capital as I've said tonight now
it's taking away the right of means
Israel to recognize the capital the
question is at what point should the
world do so and in my view in order to
achieve a long-standing peace for
Israelis and Palestinians that should
come at the time where there is a final
settlement of the whole issue thank you
very much
[Applause]
Jack Straw finishing off our opening
speeches from the floor there now is the
chance where I can give you the results
for the pre vote on your way in you
should all have told us what your gut
instinct was and I can tell you now that
before the debate before you heard
anyone here speak 27% of you were for
the motion 46% of you were against and
27 were undecided now obviously any of
those numbers can change so take heart
this side and don't be on your laurels
this side because we are here to see
what moves will not just look at the end
numbers we're looking at the direction
of travel throughout the debates and
we're going to have plenty of time to
take questions from you all from the
floor but before we do I just want to
get a little bit of a debate going with
our speakers here and pick up a little
bit on some of the points you've made
Natasha let's get to the bottom of the
flat earther stuff shall we
when you talk about flat earthing being
the same we think of that as parochial
as backwards as blind are you really
suggesting that people who pause before
seeing Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel or flattered are those people who
can't off flat earthers are blind you
don't understand that at all indeed
Emily and I think the matter can be boys
down further still and Jack Straw you
asked can Jerusalem be shared I think
the simple answer is to look at Damascus
at the minute Jack Straw who you well
let's let's get to the bottom of this
you're on record in 2005 with withdrawal
from Gaza praising the withdrawal
praising a bus for the stability he
provided in the strip and applauding the
courage of that move well look at the
bloody mess in Gaza at the moment you
were wrong there with respect you're
wrong now and I for one doubt the grip
of reality of an individual who believes
that that risen can simply be shared
not end up like the rest of the Middle
East I was actually somewhat
disappointed that first opposition
speaker in particular did not listen did
not pay attention to the to the opening
it is a great pity because I think on
the legality point it might have been
possible to learn something but I might
note I do note I must say that I have to
correct one thing I do have to correct
one thing she said I refer to the 1947
resolution I didn't with expected so I
don't want another speech let me just
come in of course very clear what do you
say that Jerusalem can't be shared are
you essentially saying there is no
two-state solution I didn't say that
that's what I'm asking you believe in a
two-state solution that is that
Jerusalem is not a part of what we must
be very clear on is look at where the
notion of a two-state solution is has
come from the important thing and the
reason I didn't mention the 1947
resolution which I have here is because
the term Palestinian is never used in it
now
why did the UN not use the term
Palestinian but rather refer to the
local Arab population at a time very
simply because it didn't exist so if
we're talking about the two-state
solution okay god I'm gonna bring you in
the context listen we existed whatever
you want to call us
front door do you have a look at me I
exist whether you want to call me you
want to call me Palestinian or you want
to call me something else I exist now in
terms of I must say this business about
Gaza and this so-called evacuation of
Gaza and how how bad it was
why is Gaza in the state you ever ask
yourself why it is that Gaza has been
subjected to an inhuman siege where
nothing virtually nothing can get in why
is that
why does Israel maintain that the people
of Gaza cannot have freedom of movement
by land by sea by air where is it
written that this is justified and this
is legal and this is something that we
could we could do it for other people
our honor I'm gonna bring you in here
you recognize that this is not an ideal
State for Israel or the Palestinians
number one Israel pulled out entirely
from Gaza in Gaza is controlled by a
terrorist organization and you deny when
you ignore it
the killers of the worst kind you know
why not because they want to kill us we
know how to deal with it they killed the
PLO they killed the Palestinians in June
of 2007
the Hamas organization brutally in the
most aggressive and violent manner
killed the hundreds of PLO activists in
Gaza killed them and threw them from the
top of the buildings because they wanted
to entirely get treated on a government
of Abu Mazen that's number one with your
permission just one thing I am
absolutely happy and surprised to hear
that in principle mr. Stroh does accept
my proposition agree the Jerusalem
should be recognized as the state as the
capital of the state of israel and and
that he says two things one that it
should be subject to an agreement I
propose the agreement of a two-state
solution with an Israeli withdrawal on
the basis of 67 lines you hear me mr.
robb 67 lines the Palestinians didn't
respond that's number one number two I
didn't I suggested the suburbs of
Jerusalem will be the Palestinian
capital every part that was in our part
of Jerusalem should be part of the
Palestinian capital in Jerusalem the
Jewish city should remain the capital of
the State of Israel as it is now what
I'm saying is only one thing which I
must say for a person that was in the
top government positions for so many
years you stupid I'm gonna bring justice
end of the sentence what you say is that
the to the city of Jerusalem shall be
shared by two different countries I
don't know in the history of mankind
that the citizens of one city were
citizens of two different countries
that's what you proposed this is
unrealistic
this is an imaginary cat sir and what I
will suggest is that the are part will
be the capital of the Palestinians and
the Jewish part will be the capital of
the State of Israel as it is and that is
the only possible solution practical
solution that can be implemented between
the two of us
[Applause]
I applaud I do the the fact that you
stood up for the 67 borders it's it's a
pity that some others within politics in
Israel have not done so and have sought
continually to change the facts on the
ground so those borders become less and
less relevant the second thing is that
as you know it's always been a part of a
possibility of a settlement that West
Jerusalem should be the capital of
Israel and East Jerusalem should be the
capital of a Palestinian state and I
mean you mock the idea of a shared
capital but that is your ought not only
mocking me which might be easy enough
but you're you're also at Atlas locking
our prime minister who says that
Jerusalem should be the ultimately
the shared capital of the Israeli and
Palestinian state yes it's very
difficult to find international
analogies for the current position
between Israel and the Palestinians
because none exists
there is nowhere else in the world where
Palestinians are equivalent of
Palestinians and Israelis with all the
very difficult history have to live
cheek-by-jowl so we do have to find and
we have to carry on trying to find a
solution to this near intractable
problem but I don't believe that it is
completely intractable and it's so
important for the people of Israel as
well as that of the Palestinian area not
least as many and my last point as many
thoughtful people within Israel point
out that the nature of the demography on
the ground that not very many decades
hence Israel is going to face this
really serious dilemma
a whether it can be both a Jewish and
democratic state at the same time
achieving a settlement is critical for
Israel as it is for the Palestinians
[Applause]
Natasha a last word to you before we
move on do you recognize that this is
not in the interest that Donald Trump's
move the Trump administration's move is
not in the interests of many Israelis
many Jews living in Jerusalem or in
Israel absolutely not and Theresa May
was wrong when she said that the
recognitions in it is unhelpful what it
does is display a fundamental lack of
understanding of the situation the
dynamic of the Palestinian leadership
there is a reason that when Obama took a
foolish position on settlements Mahmoud
Abbas was the one to say how can I be
less Palestinian than the President of
the United States what this position
what Mays comments what the position of
the UK does is hamstrung the Palestinian
leadership because they can't come to
the negotiation table when in reality
everyone knows that Jerusalem is no
longer there we've moved on from the
position that Prime Minister Olmert had
put forward they can't come back from
that negotiation table and face their
people when the international community
still believe in the Flat Earth scenario
okay so we are at a state where you're
saying Jerusalem is no longer there you
actually think it's been taken off the
table now well it's been on the table so
many times and it's been flatly rejected
because of course there is a distinction
between the first and second speakers on
the proposition the second speaker says
he recognizes in Israel in
internationally recognized borders
whatever those are but of course the
first speaker doesn't her problem is
with Israel as a whole and she said on
on previous occasions that the whole of
Israel is let go to come back on that do
you not recognize the State of Israel in
any shape I am NOT going to have this
discussion the question because
what you directly I'm not because this
is an old trick divert the discussion
we're talking about non-functional body
if had we directly do you recognize any
rate of Israel in any shape of force we
recognize the State of Israel that is
not what we're talking about this
evening we're talking about Jerusalem
I'm gonna open it up and I've no but
very quickly I have to tell you doormat
shouting you know and raising your voice
doesn't make you right right consider
that a first formal ticking off I'm
going to open it to the floor now yes
not ok I hope everyone can hear me my
name's Ambrose in writ
I'm from campaign for truth and I would
like to ask it gone I can I have your
name fully got a commie yeah yesterday
in the Palestinian mission outside the
Palestinian mission there was a
demonstration and the demonstration was
the Palestinian mission against the
Palestinian Authority I don't know if
anyone knew of you went and I'm gonna
bring you to your question is what do
you mean because I've seen your many
events from the river to the sea
Palestine will be free be free from what
exactly that means the eradication of
the Jewish people from the State of
Israel there is no other explanation for
that okay you want thank you God will
come to you in a second there's two
other hands yes who's got my second mic
you sir sorry hello I'd like to ask
garnet Asha this question please as the
grandson of a Palestinian refugee myself
Jerusalem is also very important part of
my own family's identity as a as a
descendant of Palestinians so I'd like
to just simply ask you what should we do
to Jerusalem my grandfather was born in
Jerusalem should we just simply cast
away over 1,000 years old heritage and
just put it back into the past what
should we do
thank you sir and you've got the third
mic at the top there hello my name is
David I'm a lawyer two questions one for
Garda Garda do you recognize the right
of Israel to exist and a question for
Jack Straw Jack do you think London
should be shared as a capital with
another non sovereign entity okay I
think we've covered your last point
already but if I take you back to an
gada this is starting with you do you
want to explain do you remember saying
that phrase from the river to the sea
Palestine will be free is that something
that you've said it's such explain this
is a slogan that's used by Palestinian
solidarity groups because what it's
referring to is the fact that
Palestinians living in the territory
from the river to the sea are ruled by
Israel whether they are in the 67
territories or whether they are in 48
Israel they're all ruled by Israel and
they are not free that's what that means
they are not free and they have every
right to be free so there's nobody
talking about throwing Jews out or
killing Jews or any of that that is
something I fear I'm sorry it's in your
own mind
now this little it must be in your own
mind the the second I think that I'm
gonna give the second one - no just pick
up and saying the Mahmoud Abbas has used
that phrase meaning it would be a Jew
Free State no no no no no nobody nobody
there is nobody I know who's talking
about a Jew Free State amongst the
Palestinian okay we many other let me
tell you we have a wonderful vision
which is that we share the land we share
the land between us and the Jewish
Israelis that is the proper humane
vision god I thank all this propaganda
and not that usually independent state
not that's independent state of Israel
okay independent state what words loss
of us not bring laundering this
terminology doesn't I certainly don't
think that outing is strong argument but
and I I entirely agree and I apologize
to you if you felt it I am shouting at
you but I felt that you are trying to
spread fake statements that have nothing
to do with reality about the
Palestinians about the Hamas and about
now what you say is a shirt shirt state
between the river and the sea but not an
independent Palestinian state separated
okay well Natasha is the one that's
gonna want to the question of the I'm
going to call you Palestinian grandson
because you didn't say your name what is
the vision then for his relatives and
your ownselves and your generations now
what is that Jerusalem how is it shared
okay will on the Arab population of
Jerusalem I've spoken to East Jerusalem
i'ts they are still in limbo because the
constantly failed negotiations but the
ordinary East Jerusalem might in the
street the last thing that they want is
to be ruled over by the corrupt
Palestinian Authority with the threat of
a violent Hamas takeover at any moment
the people whose rights that the
operative opposition claimed to support
these people that I spoke to moved from
areas designated for the Palestinian
Authority in order to remain under
Israeli jurisdiction in order to remain
as amongst the only free Arabs in the
Middle East and Israeli Arabs are the
only free Arabs in the Middle East they
have full political human rights civic
rights they serve at every level of
society as members of parliament in the
government so you're saying they prefer
to be governed by israel well they did
these
put base for the alternative and trust
me I'll go back to the earlier point
Gaza nowadays doesn't look in many
respects that dissimilar from Damascus
because they are also ruled by a
despotic authoritarian corrupt goes
without saying but a very well a
terrorizing force in in the name of
Hamas I'm just gonna be a dollar do you
agree with Natasha I know you're on the
same side but would you go along with
this analogy of Damascus look I I said
what I say but more important as a Prime
Minister of Israel not in a meeting like
this
okay on on a public debate not in a
friendly party in the official table of
negotiations I proposed this to the
Palestinian leader which is one an
independent Palestinian state on the
basis of 67 lines now you talk all the
time about you say about Jerusalem and
you talk about everything else because
this is easier to argue with us that we
control all the Palestinians I propose
to pull out on the basis of 67 lines
number two I play don't get into the
pajamas Jerusalem will be the capital of
the Palestinian tomates never got a
listen answer God it wasn't negotiating
with you at the time but if you were in
those shoes in the Abbas shoes can you
see a way that he should have said yes
to that do you think that was a mistake
to have turned down that offer I can't
second-guess him but I'm sure you can
speak very well sure that the offer
would have been not as generous as our
friend is making out here secondly
secondly secondly mr. Olmert it is stop
talking about the two states
that option has been foreclosed by your
colleague Benjamin Netanyahu there is no
possibility of two-stage okay I'm gonna
go to the audience now because I want to
bring lots more hands in we've got about
15 minutes I'm looking for female hands
as well yes you've had your hand up a
long time yes you ma'am and then a chap
right next to number three thank you
it saddens me to hear this because I
grew up in Israel from universe time mm
we can hear you but I didn't mana I grew
up in Israel and I'm a daughter of
refugees from Europe there's almost
nobody left alive and I feel for the
Palestinian cause but they have to feel
for us too we need our state I find it
very sad with saddened with Jack Straw
that he talks about an occupied West
Bank and I come to the question why has
a nobody ever raised the issue the
deterred Amiens invaded West Bank
preventing dust the creation of an
Iranian state and when they were given
the chance not to invade Israel King
Hussein did invade Israel in 67 okay in
after dead just they didn't negotiate
peace in Israel sadly clanked to those
territories because nobody was top peace
we've got it is a responsibility with
the Jordanians I'm gonna let Jack Straw
answer that in a second but first let's
get yes thank you I've got a two-part
question for the young girl next to mr.
O'Mara first of all in your researches
did you happen to evaluate our stir
that's why she's certainly younger than
I am
did you avail yourself of any of the
archaeological record in which the
Israelites and the Philistines are both
attested in a set of the same series of
Egyptian Stealer at the same time from
1850 and have remained living in that
land ever since or
though more Palestinians than Jews for
much of that time did you know that and
secondly do you genuinely think that the
situation as it exists now benefits
either Jews or Palestinians and might it
not behoove us Jews to grow some
humility given our long-standing
relationship with the Palestinians and
actually lower our entrenched walls okay
thank you very much I'm being
particularly brutal with the questions
I'm sorry it's just I can see a lot of
hands I don't want to disappoint yes sir
Thanks good evening my name is Fraser
I'm 47 I come from Scotland I've got
zero bias one way or the other
Ernest but this issue makes my heart
weak it's so in just and so cruel and
it's at the heart of many of the
problems we have in the world and I
think in the title of tonight's debate
there's a dichotomy because all has
happened is that America's decided to
move its embassy that is not the world
recognized in Jerusalem as the capital
so therein lies a solution how can we
get the world to decide what the what
the solution should be and then the
protagonist should accept the UN seems
it seems you know fairly weak in this in
South Africa they had a Truth and
Reconciliation conference in the early
90s so however having some global and a
forum where people from all over the
world could come together so Sofia okay
well with the panel support a global
forum to decide the outcome of this and
with the parties agree with the outcome
okay a global forum to decide this about
the about the embassy question or about
the capital question let us pick up
first of all then with this question a
Cepheid extra if you don't mind picking
up on that do the Jordanians have a
responsibility here do they have a part
to play yes if you go back over the
history a lot of people got a
responsibility here and the Arabs
Nations made it in my view a major
mistake in 1947 in not accepting what
the United Nations had agreed in terms
of the establishment of the State of
Israel and they made an even bigger
mistake in 1967 when they decided to
launch an all-out attack on Israel and
but for the IDF would have succeeded and
many of the problems which we face now
arise from that however I say many of
the problems we face now the problems
that are faced in particularly the
occupied territories are problems of
Palestinians who were either very young
or not born at that stage and they
should not have to take responsibility
for the errors of Arab leaders 60 50
years ago so that errors have been made
and miss judgments have been made and
just wrong policies on both sides my
concerns and actually shared with our
mobs
if only well admit it is how you best
get to a final settlement and what role
the status of Jerusalem should play in
that final settlement that's the issue
just to pause for a second if you see
the boxes coming around you are we are
sort of concurrently questioning and
talking and voting let me pick up on the
question that you made and I think was
to Natasha should the Jews and I think
you said should we Jews show a bit of
humility in this does the first offer
the first step in this have to come from
the Jewish people
I mean I'll come to that just before the
reference to the Philistines is an
attempt to rewrite history that I've not
come across before but I've already
explained the origins of Palestinian
nationalism what's important to notice
course is that the Palestinians in the
West Bank and those in the Gaza Strip
are very different they're different in
dialect in culture in appearance and
that's because they come from different
places the most common name in the Gaza
Strip amongst Palestinian Arabs is
Alomar's room it means the Egyptian
which is where many of them originally
come from so let us bear in mind the
reality of the people that now identify
themselves as
Athenians I have no truck with that
garden and I wish and I hope and I yearn
for peace
the issue with risk the issue you have
no truck with it if God calls herself a
Palestinian no and I have no truck for
that now it matter what I what I what I
must insist against is this notion that
this identity existed 70 years ago
because if it did the UN would have
referenced it just just to answer well
to answer your question Emily no let's
deal with that one right now okay
data I really would advise you not to
start challenging the geographical
origins of particular Palestinians for
the Jewish people's plural who has come
from all sorts of places all over the
world that's an incredibly dangerous
argument for you to deploy
very briefly I've just so also just
outlined what the position is today but
importantly in the question here is
whether we learn from history and I
think that goes to the answer to your
point because Israelis have seen over
the last 70 years that every time they
make concessions
the result is blood on the streets only
a crazy person can be expected to do the
same thing over and over again and
expect a different okay I'm gonna let
garner come in on that one I don't know
what these concessions are that you're
talking about I haven't come across any
of them but really you know you must
again sorry I don't mean to scold you
but you you really do need to be clear
that the people of Gaza and the people
of the West Bank are Palestinians
they're the same people they are
separated by an Israeli regime of
draconian regime which prevents the
people of Gaza from going to visit their
relatives and the West Bank there are
the same people let's say get that quite
straight and al Masri for your
information is a well-known Nablus
family so on this panel and then we're
going to ask you to summarize yeah well
I have a chance yes number one talking
about you turning back to 67 lines when
was Gaza United with the West Bank never
now this is not an incident this is not
a mistake that miscomi say a maid she
doesn't want to recognize the separate
existence of the State of Israel is a
sovereign state therefore she argues
about this Gaza in the West Bank they
never were united they always were
separated before 67 they were separated
because that's number one they were
separated because their arms in the Arab
countries were against the 47 partition
resolution they were against it not
we voted for you they were against you
that's number one number two we can go
into a debate about the history and
about the geographical limits this is
something that all those who are not
prepared to look to the future
finding so so delightful to be indulged
in okay I don't want to argue about the
history I am talking about the present
situation yes I am in favor of two
states an independent Palestinian state
in borders based not identical based
literally to the last centimeter on 67th
right and Jerusalem is the capital of
the state of israel and the arc
Jerusalem is the capital of the for the
king and si who support we are running
out of time
yeah position very quickly a small point
to a mr. Olmert before 1948 before there
was an Israel Gaza and the West Bank
were part of the same country and they
are the same people which come it is res
rel which country meets what was then
their country in Palestine you're
running out of time ladies and gents
this is what our closing speeches are
for I am sorry that we didn't get two
more questions and Fraser from Scotland
perhaps our speakers want to just
incorporate a little bit of that thought
is it time for a global forum to look at
this objectively it's a big ask that in
two minutes we're going to do that in
reverse order you should all have voted
by now and then I'm going to bring you
the final tally so I'm going to ask Jack
Straw if you would now go first thank
you very much
what first time I was asked whether
London should be a shared capital well
this it doesn't arise because there is
as it were one people's we should
covered by London and as I go back to my
earlier point the situation in the
Middle East
and I will not least over the status of
Jerusalem is unique there isn't any
parallel anywhere else in the world
which is why we have to find a special
solution for the problem um I finished
really where I began like our own what I
strongly believe in a two-state solution
based on the 67 borders it can only
happen as Prime Minister Theresa May has
said by negotiation in those
negotiations each side has got to give
concessions
one of the critical concessions which
was always there - as it were a card to
be played in those negotiations up until
and still is internationally until
Donald Trump's unilateral decision about
the Accord he gets to Jerusalem was the
status of Jerusalem and my view last
point is that those negotiations will be
facilitated by continuing to retain the
question of the status of Israel
internationally until there is a final
settlement of this issue thank you Jack
Straw thank you very much you have two
minutes for your closing speech I want
to repeat Simon hey we can't escape it
we can't ignore it and we can't run away
from it it can be only one solution that
I believe can create an entirely new
momentum for the Israelis and the
Palestinians and the entire Middle East
and this solution is based on two states
one for the Palestinians one for the
Israelis the State of Israel exists the
Palestinian state has to be created we
ought to pull out from the territories
this was the position of the Israeli
government
was never never adopted on that basis by
the Palestinian Authority
regrettably now miscomi
wants to suggest it i wasn't genuine and
I proposed it to Abu Mazen Abu Mazen say
time and again publicly and I can refer
you even to the 11th of February 2011 to
the New York time magazine where he and
me were interviewed together
I mean separately but for the same for
the same article and he said about all
that I say then that I said I proposed
to him that it is a hundred percent
accurate so he thought that this was
genuine he had problems difficulties I
don't care what I say is this this is
the only way to do it and Rosalyn is the
capital of the State of Israel will
forever be the capital of the state of
israel and the only way to convince the
Palestinians to sit down a concluded is
to recognize that fact by the
international community
[Music]
gotta call me your two-minute closing
speech yeah listen I am fine much
they're really very depressed to listen
to this stuff honestly you know
defending the indefensible is an art
that many Israelis have perfected and
many Jewish supporters of Israel but but
the reality is the reality is that the
Palestinian people have been produced
their rights have been produced what
this is really about is the fact that a
very great injustice has been committed
against the Palestinians and the idea
that Israel can put itself forward as
some kind of enlightened entity as a
hood omelet would like to say is not is
free almost obscene because of the
effect now just two very quick comments
on the the question of two states I know
that a hood omelet
is very keen on this because it was
something that he achieved that he
believes were something he put forward
and he believes was a very noble gesture
on his part
the trouble is mr. on that it's in the
past it's gone it isn't possible to talk
about to States and it was never just
any way to have had two states it is my
contention and that of so many people I
know Palestinians and Jews and Jewish
Israelis that the only way forward for
this awful conflict is for us to share
the land share the land and create one
Democratic state for all of us that is
the only just solution
jarred akami thank you very much
our last closing speech Natasha Houston
well they say you can only make peace
with your enemy but that's half the
equation isn't it your enemy needs to
want to make peace with you and nothing
can happen until they reconcile
themselves with your very existence I
want to be clear the Palestinian people
are being oppressed by a genocidal
dictatorial terrorist regime called
Hamas and the corrupt Palestinian
Authority I have never had any truck
with Palestinians and neither have my
family in fact before the terror they
were in and out everyone into Gaza and
the West Bank
what happened Palestinian terror that
necessitated separation so we need to be
clear on that point and in my experience
the majority of Palestinians I come
across don't have much talk with
Israelis unless they are indoctrinated
from kindergarten as they currently now
on the Gaza Strip to believe that the
highest calling in life is to kill as
many as Raley's as possible the issue on
deaths is one that I find incredibly
distressing because between 300,000 and
half a million people have been killed
in Syria so far where is the
international outrage Dan Gilman an
ambassador to the UN once said something
that you'll have to look up because I'm
out of time
but ladies and gentlemen it encapsulated
the heart of this conflict part of the
battle is to dispel these lies and I
have no compunction in doing so
[Music]
it's crunch time you've heard the debate
you've heard the speeches you've heard
the questions from the floor and I'm
going to remind you now of the figures
at the start of the evening as you came
in 27% of you were for the motion 27% of
you believed the world should recognize
Jerusalem as Israel's capital 46 percent
of you were against that motion and 27
percent of you were undecided at the end
of the evening in favor of the motion 37
percent against the motion 61 percent
undecided has shrunk down to just 2
percent so we've got rid of all those
people who couldn't make up their mind
they have now firmly made up their mind
it is a swing vote of 3 percent and it
just remains me to thank all of you for
coming and are excellent phenomenal
speakers for showing so much of their
thoughts receiving
you